la course d'une vie peut-être à 25 ans
seulement charles rozoy ligne d'eau
numéro quatre monnaies le et blanc
départ extraordinaire ce matin lors des
séries il peut gagner encore quelques
centièmes
il peut surtout aller chercher le graal
c'est sans doute la concession
allez c'est parti avec le bon
jaillissement de charles rozoy ligne
d'eau numéro 4 qui sort en tête tout de
suite avec à ses côtés song le chinois
également le gros départs ligne d'eau
numéro deux avec son bonnet blanc tout
en haut de votre écran de tara sauf le
russe tara sauf qu'ils accélèrent
maintenant charles rozoy qui est ici en
gros plan et qui va virer sans doute en
deuxième position les partis sur des
bases extrêmement rapide par rapport à
ce matin avec le russe qui est en tête
mais c'est au virage sur la deuxième
longueur que charles rozoy deuxième pour
l'instant avait fait le travail ce matin
charles rozoy qui sont en deuxième
position avec également le retour ligne
d'eau numéro 3 de wei le vice champion
paralympique en titre charles rozoy qui
tentent de revenir à temps il reste 25
mètres une demi-longueur moins d'une
demi longueur pour revenir et charles
rozoy le dijonnais 25 ans qui va aller
chercher qui va aller s'offrir son
premier titre paralympique charles rozoy
mr butterfly est sous vos yeux
changeront joie qui s'impose dans un
chrono qui importe peu à l'arrivée une
île 24 mais surtout le titre de champion
paralympique pour un charles rozoy roi
du monde ce soir le premier titre
également pour la france il a nagé tout
près de son record de france mais
l'important n'était pas là il fallait
s'imposer ce soir et le dijonnais l'a
fait devant le vice champion
paralympique et wake qui une nouvelle
fois prend la deuxième place 3e place
pour song et wang les chinois étaient là
mais l'empereur du milieu à la lidho
numéro 4 s'appelle charles rozoy exploit
colossal pour le nageur français
mon côté j'avais un rêve et vous savez
on à l'école on vous toujours une
question quand on est petit quand vous
arrivez au début de l'année on vous
demande qu'est ce que tu veux faire plus
tard
et moi je répondais je veux être
champion olympique et la prof médias non
mais t'as pas compris que la question
qu'est ce que tu veux faire plus tard
comme laitiers si champion olympique
était vraiment tu es tu toi tu vas te
mettre au fond de la classe et quand ce
sera ce que tu veux faire plus tard tu
reviendras et ça c'est une ritournelle
dans ma vie j'ai toujours voulu être
champion olympique mais je savais même
pas de quoi à l'époque pour vous dire et
j'ai découvert que la natation un petit
peu plus tard et après je me suis dit je
vais être champion olympique de natation
alors je savais pas comment il fallait
faire mon m'a dit c'était très fort
tu pourras rentrée en sport études alors
j'ai nagé beaucoup très jeune au collège
je suis rentré en sport études
le sport études ça permet de manger tous
les jours et puis d'avoir des études
aménagé avec transport et puis on m'a
dit on m'a fait rêver
on m'a dit c'était vraiment très fort tu
pourras aller au pôle espoir vous faire
des beaux et là je me suis entraîné dur
et je suis rentrée au pôle espoir au
lycée alors le pôle espoir ça te
permettait d'aménager son lycée et de
pouvoir faire les lycées sur 4 ans est
de passer son bac en quatre ans et
entraînait un petit peu plus que tu te
reconnais entre 30 et 40 heures par
semaine et dans cette période là
pourtant j'étais que champion du monde
de l'entraînement
le champion du monde de l'entraînement
c'est simple c'est à dire que j'étais
capable de faire des choses
exceptionnelles un entraînement mais
quand j'arrivais en compétition il y
avait plus personne
j'étais quatrième au pied du podium à
quelques centièmes du taux international
et mon entraîneur a d'ailleurs me disait
souvent il faudrait peut-être nager un
petit peu plus vite ça mais j'avais
tendance à faire des choses
exceptionnelles notamment dans cette
période j'ai nagé 12h sur les 12 heures
de natation et j'ai battu le record en
faisant 42 km et je me rappelle sortir
de l'eau complètement épuisé rincer et
mon coach me regarde et me dit c'est
bien mais ça sert à rien
merci peau tu dis oui c'est vrai tu
l'objectif c'est d'être d'être champion
c'est pas de faire des guignols
d'affaires 42 km c'est vrai qu'il ait
jamais mis dans mon cv 42 km en 12
heures je sais pas si ça sert à
quelqu'un aujourd'hui de faire ça mais
j'aurais pu mettre à titre de champion
de france mais j'en étais pas capable et
on arrive à la fin du lycée
mon coach me dit écoute tu as trois
solutions la première je fais un podium
aujourd'hui en france
la deuxième tu fais internationale la
troisième des virées vous imaginez bien
j'ai fais quatrième à deux centièmes du
temps internationale donc j'ai été viré
et la vo rêve s'effondre que j'avais
même pas ce que je voulais faire
apparaître champion olympique donc je me
suis posé beaucoup de questions mais
surtout je tombé en dépression
c'est quelque chose que je souhaite à
personne surtout à cet âge là 19 ans se
posait beaucoup de questions et et j'ai
fait un petit peu n'importe quoi je suis
rentré en médecine puisque oui mon
deuxième rêve c'était d'être chirurgien
j'avais pas des rêves facile mais quand
le cot le prof voulais vraiment pas
décroché qu'est ce que tu veux faire
comme métier jeudi champion olympique
chirurgien mais bon je me suis accroché
je vais en médecine ne s'est pas duré
très longtemps sur les bancs de médecine
c'est surtout cette dépression qui m'a
gagné j'ai pris 30 kilos en quelques
mois
et là j'étais au fond du seau un jour je
me réveille après le soir et un petit
peu trop arrosée et je me pose plein de
questions et je dis mais qu'est ce que
tu fais là qu'est ce que tu fais
pourquoi tu prends la caisse qui ce
qu'est ce que tu veux et j'ai réfléchi
je n'oppose sur le canapé un peu
embrumés mais si tu je veux être heureux
questions faciles réponse facile ça m'a
pas dit comment fallait que je sois là
je dis bon bah je vais te pragmatique je
vais faire une petite liste
alors je fais une check-list j'ai pas
mis la ferrari dedans et puis le compte
1000 km an avec 1 million non j'ai pas
du tout ça j'ai mis des choses un peu
tout ce que je pouvais avoir et qui
pouvait me rendre heureux et je me suis
rendu compte au fur et à mesure que
j'écrivais que je faisais c'est ici
qu'elle avait tout ce qu'il fallait je
me suis dit mais alors pourquoi tu es
pauvre question simple encore parce que
tu ne le veut pas donc je me suis dit ce
jour là je veux être heureux et je me
suis dit tu as tous les jours tu vas te
dire devant la glace je veux être
heureux
je me suis battu et je suis devenu
heureux comme ça petit à petit ça fait
pas passer en deux jours je vous rassure
le lendemain j'étais pas là
mon peuple tout va bien mais il a fallu
un petit peu de temps mais je suis
devenu heureux et puis j'ai repris des
études les études de staps sciences et
techniques des activités physiques et
sportives pour devenir prof de sport
preuve de ps tous les métiers du sport
et dans cette période là les profs
savent très bien s'y faire et m'ont dit
tu pourrais arnage et ça devrait plus de
points donc du coup je suis allé nager
et je m'entraînais je m'entraînais de
nouveau j'ai reperdu un peu de poids je
suis redevenu l'homme que je voulais
être et surtout en juin 2008 je deviens
champion de france du 50 m papillon
ben si c'est bon championne france tous
mes rêves sont réalisables
les plus grandes équipes me rappelle et
me disent bon bachar tu ferais pas venir
nager avec nous je me dis tout est
possible finalement choisi de continuer
avec mon coach celui qui avait été
honnête avec moi qui m'avait poussée
dans mes retranchements avec qui j'avais
pas forcément su être le meilleur mais
je me dis tout est possible et le 26
juillet 2008 alors que j'étais maître
nageur sur un bassin pas loin de dijon
je rentre du travail en moto un
chauffard va me couper la route
je vais voler pas longtemps je vous
rassure parce qu'après on s'écrase
et puis je vais rencontrer une barrière
de sécurité la jeune de rendre compte
que la barre et de sécurité plus fort
que mon bras puisque mon bras va passer
dans la barrière et ça va faire crac et
j'ai une fracture ouverte de l'humérus
je me retrouve à l'hôpital
et là les médecins me disent mais vous
inquiétez pas monsieur rousseau vous
avez une fracture on la répare et tout
va bien se passer quelle d'ici quelques
mois tout ira mieux là je me vois déjà
champion olympique
pourquoi pas moi d'autres l'avaient
réussi alexandre popov ce grand nageur
qui était poignardé et qui est revenu au
plus haut niveau après pourquoi pas moi
et donc je m'accroche à ce rêve
et là je passe des journées dans mon lit
d'hôpital il fait chaud c'est l'été et
j'attends j'attends un jour j'ai une de
ses envie de faire pipi et je regarde
des toilettes fut alité dans mon lit
j'appelle des infirmières pour qu'elle
vienne parce que on fait pipi caca dans
son lien quand on est alité et personne
n'arrive être au coeur des toilettes
j'ai l'impression de monsieur propre
vient de passer
mais non il n'est pas passé mais là je
prends ma paire je vais aux toilettes et
le soulagement de bonheur vous
connaissez ça aussi
hélas les infirmières entre en hurlant
dans la chambre mais qu'est ce que vous
faites monsieur reçoit c'est dangereux
faut pas vous levez ça fait plusieurs
semaines que vous êtes dans votre lit
c'est dangereux ça mais vous marchez
monsieur rozoy bah oui j'ai pas les gens
me couper un peu
venez nous dire et là j'ai compris que
personne ne prendrait jamais par la main
et donc c'était le début d'un nouveau
défi un défi de partir de l'hôpital
je suis allé voir le médecin je lui ai
dit écoutez moi je veux rentrer chez moi
m'a dit c'est pas parce que vous êtes
lever et aller aux toilettes que vous
pouvez marcher et allait bien je le dis
quand nous ferait le tour de l'hôpital
en marchant on en reparlera je suis
parti avec ma paire je me suis assis sur
un banc au bout d'une semaine j'ai fait
le tour de l'hopital il a été obligé de
me relâcher et puis bon voilà les les
jours sauf avancé le braille tout
bougeait toujours pas je ne bougeais
toujours pas mon bras j'avais le bras
complètement inerte et là je me retrouve
chez une visite chez un médecin
et ce médecin de m me faire des examens
il planquait d aiguille dans le bras on
enfants cette aiguille il dit vous
sentez la jeune en revanche sans rien et
puis le plan des villans et puis l'envoi
des coûts de vue puis d'un côté de la
main qui fait sens et l'autre côté ça
bouge pas puis commence à prendre un air
grave
lire habillez-vous je me rhabille ai dit
monsieur heureusement assez grave je
vais me planter des aiguilles depuis
tout à l'heure dans le bras j'ai bien vu
que c'était quand même
non c'est vraiment grave faut pas
rigoler
votre vie est foutue vous avez un bras
qui marche put marchera plus jamais le
sport c'est fini votre carrière dans de
professionnels du sport c'est fini il
faut arrêter faudra faire autre chose je
peux vous dire j'ai pas beaucoup pleuré
pendant tout le monde accident mais à ce
moment là il ya une larme qui m'a
échappé caisse commencé à couler sur ma
joue il y met monsieur rozoy vous allez
pas chialer c'est pas comme si vous
venez de sida vous n'avez pas en crever
non plus
voilà la pédagogie dans tous ont marre
j'aurais pu rencontrer amener ça un
petit peu plus pédagogue ce que j'ai
fait très peu de temps après puisque
j'ai rencontré un grand chirurgien que
je remercie encore aujourd'hui
professeur oberlin qui à paris m'a opéré
et m'a très vite dit l'homme implique
qu'il devra calmer les nerfs qui sont
arrachés au niveau de la moelle épinière
qui nerv le bras et et qui m'a empêché
de bouger ils m'ont dit bon ben voilà on
va vous opérer au mieux vous récupérez
ça au moins bien ça c'était très clair
très cadré mais à dix mais avec un bras
on peut faire plein de choses
ne dit on peut tout à fait vivre sa vie
avec un bras d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
gelée vue puisque j'ai j'aurais pas le
temps dans toute ma vie de faire ce que
je veux avec mais avec un seul bras donc
un coin de quoi ça me servais d'en avoir
deux parce que je rêve j'aurais pu faire
encore plus de choses donc voilà donc
nous voilà au père et à attendre que ça
récupère et puis je fais mes séances de
rééducation puis arrive à la piscine
parce que mon thiney me dit ce serait
bien que tu ailles à la piscine pour
faire des séances de récupération doré
moins mal ça serait plus simple
et là je suis dans l'eau comme ça dans
le petit bassin là où j'ai passé des
heures et des heures à nager puis comme
ça dans le petit bassin à bouger mon
bras ça fait mal c'est dur pied des
petits jeunes qui posent sur le bord du
bassin qui viennent s'entraîner six sept
ans à peu près à l'âge où j'ai commencé
la natation et je rêvais d'être champion
olympique mois et ces jeunes me regarder
ils font retient ce héros doit qu'est-ce
qui nageait bien avant maintenant elle
est foutue fait de l'aquagym
mais je dis ça va pas le faire je suis
sorti de l'eau
je vais les voir jadis vous dites est
comme ça dans l'eau nanananère on va
faire une course sans voir kiss & kill
foutu je me suis attaché le bras on a
fait une course lors m une tôle
forcément et là il y avait mon coach qui
était de l'autre côté qui traverse qui
vient me voir qu'il a à me voir et
qu'ils dînaient voiture prendrait pas la
natation jeudi coup de coach fait
tourner agi pour pour gagner qu'est ce
que tu veux que je fasse avait nagé avec
un bras j'y arriverai jamais je serai
jamais champion il dit mais tu préfères
du handisport
je le regrette je vais leur dit sport
c'est pour les handicapés ledit
réfléchit à ta réponse et tu reviens me
voir je suis rentré chez moi j'ai pris
mon temps
depuis la survenue de voir j'ai dit
écoute écoute c'est un projet de devenir
champion paralympique mais dit c'est ça
ton projet on y va et donc voilà me
voilà repartie dans l'eau on était en
janvier 2009 six mois après mon accident
je leur manager championnats de france
en mars devient champion de france
tiens je réitère en juin je deviens de
nouveau championne france je me qualifie
pour les championnats d'europe les
championnats du monde en octobre je fais
les premiers championnats d'europe et
devient champion d'europe en novembre je
deviens champion du monde
puis il est sûr compétition change m et
quand vous avez pu le voir j'ai réussi à
réaliser mon rêve
en 2012 le 30 août 2012 à londres en
devenant champion paralympique
après cette intervention généralement on
pose toujours une question c'est oui moi
je suis un projet mais je rêve pas
d'être champion olympique
et puis toute façon dans la vie
l'important c'est 2 l'importance et deux
oui ben c'est pas vrai
alors il semblerait qu'un mec qui
s'appelle pierre de coubertin est dit
l'important c'est de participer
mais c'est pas vrai il a dit l'important
c'est de participer mais seule la
victoire est belle
ça change un petit peu la phrase je dis
ça comme ça l'important c'est pas de
participer l'important c'est de faire
l'amère toi-même se dépasser de ne rien
regretter d'aller jusqu'au bout pour ne
rien regretter
donc aujourd'hui voilà je voulais
partager ça avec vous vous dire que
l'important c'est qu'on a tous des rêves
qu'est ce que vous êtes prêts à
sacrifier pour réaliser vos rêves
qu'est ce que vous êtes prêts à faire
puisque vous voulez vraiment ça la
question est ce que vous êtes prêts à
tout donner pour réaliser le meilleur du
pire
[Applaudissements]